[Music]
hi my name is yufeng guo and today we're
going to look at how tensorflow
enterprise or tfe
builds on tensorflow to enable the
seamless creation of production machine
learning applications with
enterprise-grade support
through the power of google cloud to
learn about the benefits of tfe let's
imagine a scenario where a data
scientist visits an ops team to ask for
help productionizing their machine
learning platform
the question then becomes whether there
is a suitable platform for both
experimentation and production
tensorflow enterprise is ideal for this
kind of situation
google cloud has your solution to
productionize your tensorflow
applications
as part of google cloud tfe provides
managed services
cloud scale performance and enterprise
grade support
let's start with managed services and
check back in to see how our data
science and ops teams are doing
the data science team needs development
environments with lots of compute power
and in an on-prem non-managed system the
burden of setting them up often falls to
the ops team
[Music]
there are many challenges to operating
this way machines with gpus are
expensive and take a long time to
acquire
software installation and management
consume significant time
additionally there's the problem of over
provisioning
this kind of non-managed ml platform
doesn't scale for enterprise production
projects
one solution to these constraints is to
introduce a standardized ml platform for
the data scientists and ops teams
to solve these problems enter tensorflow
enterprise on the deep learning vm
or dlvm the dlvm is a standardized
vm image for machine learning
applications tfe currently supports
tensorflow 1.15 and
2. the machine comes pre-installed with
the everyday tools for data scientists
including cuda drivers numpy sklearn
pandas and of course jupiter
since it's a standardized software stack
it's easily manageable by ops engineers
the dlvm is deployable to google cloud
with google compute engine or ai
platform notebooks
in just a few minutes also there's no
over provisioning problem because you
only pay for the resources you actually
use
minute by minute let's take a look at
how you can actually create a gce
instance with the dlvm image in the gcp
console head on over to the compute
engine's vm instances page and click
create select marketplace from the left
hand menu and type deep learning vm in
the search bar
select the deep learning vm and click
launch in this menu you can select your
machine type and if you want gpus
you can also select the tensorflow
enterprise versions 1.15
and 2. for now let's choose tensorflow
1.15 without gpus
and just one cpu a very simple image and
just click
deploy the manageability you just saw
increases the portability and
scalability that you just can't get
with local notebooks there's often a
huge gap between
proof of concept notebooks and
production machine learning code
for example notebooks are often
particular to the local environment of
each data scientist
but production code should be portable
and shareable
a single notebook instance can't serve
10 million users
the ops teams have to take on a lot of
work to scale and load balance to build
a production system
proof of concepts are manually deployed
whereas in production the ops team needs
to manage a reproducible end-to-end
life cycle and after all of that
continuous monitoring and alerting still
need to be taken into consideration
one way to fill the gap between
experimentation and production
is deep learning containers or dlc with
tensorflow enterprise
dlc provides the exact same standardized
ml software stack as a dlvm
with support for tensorflow 1.15 and 2
as well as lots of common data science
libraries but now it's on a portable and
scalable container image
if your data science team is already
using dlvms then it's much easier for
ops engineers to migrate their code to
dlc and deploy it to google cloud
services such as ai platform and
kubernetes engine
with deep learning containers the ops
team won't have to add a hundred
thousand lines of code to make a robust
system for example if you use ai
platform or kubernetes engine to run the
container
you automatically get the benefits from
the managed service such as container
scheduling and lifecycle management
scaling out to load balancing and
failover logging and monitoring
troubleshooting security and more
now let's see how scale cloud
performance of tensorflow enterprise can
benefit you
in many cases data scientists tend to
use smaller sample data sets for
building their machine learning models
and don't bother handling the raw big
data so
it falls to the ops team to design an ml
pipeline that can accommodate the 10
million rows from storage without any i
o bottleneck
and continuously and smoothly
pre-process and train the model
every day because tensorflow enterprise
provides tensorflow runtimes
specifically designed for google cloud
you can fully utilize the cloud scale
performance of both cloud storage
and bigquery with minimal changes to
your existing tensorflow code
lastly let's talk about enterprise grade
support the pace of ai and software
versions is evolving
rapidly and it's hard to keep up with
new library versions always coming out
that is why tensorflow enterprise
includes long-term support
for tensorflow 1.15 and 2 google cloud
will provide security patches and select
bug fixes for up to
3 years these versions will be available
on google cloud and all patches and bug
fixes will also be available
in the mainline tensorflow repository
tensorflow enterprise is available today
with support for tensorflow 1.15 and 2.
speed up your software development and
ensure the longevity and reliability of
your ai applications and services
with enterprise grade support it's the
only offering
from the same team that created
tensorflow head over to g dot co
cloud tensorflow to get started today